[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
758 1871 7,58 1849 vrai si vous êtes un
tracteur week-end
je suis en train de compter tous les
coups droits et tous les revers depuis
le début de roland garros et c'est vous
qui vous devez demander ça c'est pour
votre chronique non non pas du tour à la
voie c'était juste donc me laisser
tranquille pendant quelques instants
vous pouvez arrêter ça ne sert à rien
d'attendre c'est bourgi de bonnes
nouvelles
regardez je me suis dit est ce qu'il
voudrait pas qu'on fasse un duo patrick
sébastien et moi pour l'eurovision
et voilà il est candidat à l'horizon
2016 donc s'ils gagnent il va se casser
à l'étranger et vous prenez sa place
bon c'est sa candidature est aussi
fructueuse que c'était la présidence de
français je suis pas près de prendre sa
place un bon p'tit père ouais enfin
tombé si reed et si koné en musique
quand même regarder ce cover mais j'ai
regardé justement
bertand julien courbet va présenter un
concours de barbecue sur d8
j'ai envie de dire cheapos l'artiste ou
alors merguez l'artiste est merguez
l'artiste
j'avais quoi là je te casse la gueule ou
je te laisse un second pour prendre un
peu d'avancé
non sérieusement je vais bosser je vais
au charbon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors que le match de jo wilfried tsonga
avait commencé il a été suspendu à cause
de la chute d'un panneau publicitaire
il y aurait un blessé léger il a été
évacué tout jésus dessin par et de la
mer c'est très chose qui s'est passé
ouais pas penser surtout bien jouer un
nom mais fabrice ne dit pas que abba
cissé mois quick de coups de tournevis
mais pour vous avez fait ça et parce
qu'un una il a tout le temps roland
garros donc là j'ai dévissé la tôle et
enfin vous auriez pu le tuer ben
justement si je le tue il présente plus
touche pas à mon pote c'est pour vous
c'est sûr mais fera on va avoir sacré
paquet de merde vous avez vraiment un
pet au casque
bertrand m6 lance le casting de la
saison 2 de the island
qu'est ce que ça peut me [ __ ] et là
vous y allez vous y participez vous
remportez le jeu vous devenu célèbre et
à vous les rênes du shopping c'est très
gentil de penser à moi fabrice mais je
vois pas ce que j'irais faire dans une
émission où y'a rien à gagner une sale
ambiance au tout le monde plus de la
gueule ça ne changera pas de tpm p
bertrand bertrand au fait roland garros
la tôle là je déconnais c'était pas moi
mais c'est dès qu'ils s'étaient les
opticiens la tôle les opticiens
regardez ça fabrice gilles verdez et
jean michel maire font partie des
chroniqueurs les plus désagréables du
paf sans fait toujours de moi dans mes
palmes et en plus bertrand vous êtes
lent classement donc des plus
désagréables truc pas bref ce soir crime
sur nrj12 en direct présentée par
morandini
j'adore crime j'aimerais trop passer
dedans c'est mon rêve antoine
fabrice est votre rêve mais si vous
passez d'un crime c'est-à-dire qu'elle
soit vous avez combien de vies cible se
pose est mort et vous aimeriez faire
passer nos crimes qu est-ce que j'irai
faire dans crime
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce numéro
exceptionnel de crimes en direct nous
allons ouvrir ce soir à un dossier qui a
ému le monde médiatique il s'agit de la
sphère du pakistanais empoisonné en 2015
alors qu'il a le vent en poupe et qu'il
s'apprête à racheter des huit cyril
hanouna est retrouvé étouffé à proximité
de son plateau dans sa bouche 18
boulettes de viande et lait qui a bien
pu commettre ce geste mieux à ce jour
nous ne disposons que de quelques
indices retrouvés sur la scène de crime
un cartable une compote et un dvd de la
reine des neiges avec nous ce soir pour
en parler sur ce plateau de crimes en
direct bertrand chamerois bonjour merci
d'être avec nous avec le principal
suspect dans cette affaire d'autant plus
que vous présentez ne touche pas à mon
poste depuis 2015 ce n'est pas la
première fois que vous en preniez ainsi
à cyril hanouna
écoutez je sais que les éléments
m'accable mais je vous le dit les yeux
dans les yeux jean marc morandini je nie
en bloc et en détail toutes ces
accusations
j'ai peut-être de l'ambition oui mais
elle passe après mon intégrité et
pourtant c'est pas la première fois que
vous vous attaquez à des gens qui vous
ont aidé et qui vous ont fait débuter
dans ce métier
cd je vois vraiment pas du tout de quoi
vous voulez parler
en tout cas moi je me comprends merci
beaucoup en tout cas vers ton sang
n'aura et rendez vous ce soir en direct
à partir de 20h50 pour crime en direct
sur nrj 12
[Applaudissements]